mon projet de recherche s'est intéressé
au micro billion de la forêt tempérée
québécoises d'amiante dans un premier
temps nous avons essayé de décrire le
micro billes ont des arbres de la forêt
tempérée naturel donc quel micro
organismes présents sur un sapin ou sur
un érable et sont ils les mêmes
dans un deuxième temps nous avons essayé
de démontrer si le micro billes ont des
arbres a une influence sur la
productivité des communautés végétales
est ce que avoir un micro bien plus
diversifiés ça pourrait augmenter la
productivité de biomasse végétale en
forêt et finalement nous avons étudié le
micro billes ont des arbres le long d'un
gradient d'urbanisme de l'extérieur de
la ville de montréal jusqu'au
centre-ville
est ce que nous avons trouvé c'est que
les micro organismes sont plus
diversifiées au centre-ville soit deux
par la pollution qui a crû au
centre-ville ou aussi par la plus grande
densité des populations de la population
humaine désormais dans le cadre de mon
post doctoraux je m'intéresse au micro
biyong qui est présente dans nos
intestins plus particulièrement chez les
jeunes enfants dans les trois premières
années de vie et comment le micro
billion de l'intestin des enfants pour
influencer leurs risques de développer
des maladies auto immunes chroniques
comme l'asthme et les allergies